the Joe Rogan experience did you hear
about that lady this has nothing to do
with that what she just got convicted
today of murder she walked into the
wrong apartment
Oh a cop right yep she thought this guy
was in her apartment she shot him and
killed him she said let me see your
hands
yeah from his point of views like what
the [ __ ] are you let me see your hands
yeah and she shot him I didn't hear that
part but I just know did she shot him
and murdered him and said Emily she
thought he was in her place yeah she
yeah that's it that's like I heard her
like crawling in the sand yeah and it
was like damn but it's just like I don't
know why do you keep going to shooting
don't shoot right did the guy run at you
yeah it's like like when do you shoot
someone if you find them is the training
wrong why unarmed people are getting
shot it's not even like it's not like
that right it's just like I mean you got
it wrong at very least you got it wrong
well I've said this many times and I
think the vast majority of interactions
that people have a police are there
positive there's no problem yeah and
that's why you don't hear about them but
you hear about one every now and again
that's just because there's 300 million
people and if you could you count up all
those one every now and again it seems
like this is [ __ ] just yeah assault
on unarmed people Tories will listen to
over over statistics what's just it's
people that suck at being a cop yeah
especially girls no no offense ladies
but you're physically weaker right yeah
so you could get that gun taken from you
someone's in your house you live by
yourself maybe and you see this guy in
your house and you're so terrified
because like it's like a monster yeah
like a big man yeah it's like a monster
to a woman yeah and then at the same
time that dude is in his apartment now
I'm dead so that's also not great oh
it's terrible but like you're not
supposed to just shoot people yeah let's
just shoot into her eyes yeah if she
really thought that she was that's why I
don't understand how it's murder like
what will its what's the accident isn't
manslaughter like accidental shooting I
understand any of that how's it not
manslaughter yeah do you know I just was
following the story a little bit
I remember for some facts from a few
weeks ago that there are
a lot of there are at least three or
four things in place here that like made
it not seem like an accident like a
really like the door for instance the
door in those apartments I was reading
like it shuts automatically so she I
think she said it was like unlocked or
it was kind of open and everyone that
sort of knows about that apartment is
like that's not possible this door shut
out mapping behind you you would have
had to open the door physically she
opened the door didn't shut all the way
I don't know I think they had a
relationship maybe two or something like
that
what I don't know maybe misremembering
the facts oh listen you can't just say
that let's start googling I heard the
guy she shot was new Supreme Court
justice Cavanaugh oh yeah and he denied
her that dick after a while it's like no
more dick for you
[Applause]